SALA CONSTITUCIONAL 4º: Doctora sí ya se ha realizado.
vera ninoska: Bien, vamos a entonces instalar la audiencia correspondiente a la acción de cumplimiento planteada
vera ninoska: por Edwin, julio. Choque Huancayusco en representación de Rose Mari Choquehuanca y Edwin, Francisco huertamina contra el juez del juzgado público
vera ninoska: civil y comercial noveno de la ciudad del Alto doctor Sócrates, Henry Lunazco en el caso señorita Secretaria, tenga bien informada el cumplimiento de notificaciones, quienes hacen seguimiento de audiencia, y si el expediente, si es que ha sido remitido o qué documentación cuenta la sal.
SALA CONSTITUCIONAL 4º: La palabra, señora vocal, informar a su autoridad que la notificación a la parte accionada, así como terceros interesados con el último actuado, que cursa en el dossier constitucional, no ha sido cumplida
SALA CONSTITUCIONAL 4º: en relación a presencia de partes. Parte accionante se encuentra presente. Edwin julio Choque Huanca, en representación de los Mary Choquehuanca Yusco
SALA CONSTITUCIONAL 4º: y Edwin, Fernando huertanina asistido de su abogado el doctor oxfa parte accionar se encuentra ausente la autoridad frenada, así como los terceros interesados. Ricardo Izaga, Siles y Alicia. Beissaga de Beissaga, es cuanto tengo a bien informar para fines de registro. Señores vocales. Gracias.
vera ninoska: Bien pregunta. La parte accionada fue: o no fue notificada.
SALA CONSTITUCIONAL 4º: La palabra. Señora Vocal, no ha sido notificada a la autoridad accionada en este caso. El señor juez del juzgado público civil comercial, 9 de la ciudad del alto con el señalamiento de audiencia.
vera ninoska: Terceros interesados.
SALA CONSTITUCIONAL 4º: De igual forma, doctoras.
vera ninoska: No hay bien bien.
vera ninoska: La falta de comunicaciones hace que no sea posible desarrollar el acto
vera ninoska: debiendo exhortar parte accionante. Coadyuve con las comunicaciones, excepto que esta audiencia pueda ser desarrollada. Entendemos que que ahora nuestro diferimiento ya no corresponderá esta gestión por la alta carga laboral que tiene sala constitucional. Ya los señalamientos nos quedan para el año.
vera ninoska: Parte de accionante que está haciendo seguimiento de la audiencia. Nuevamente le exhortamos, tenga a bien dar seguimiento a su caso, efecto, que la audiencia pueda ser desarrollada de manera exitosa y cumplamos con las comunicaciones terceros interesados. Otro domicilio no puede cubrir sala de
vera ninoska: domicilios que no conoce con esa aclaración. El diferimiento del acto, lo vamos a realizar para el día, 14 de enero a horas 14 p m accionante. Queda ya debidamente comunicado, exhortado y realícense las comunicaciones, correspondientes. Repito 14 de enero, 14 p.
vera ninoska: no habiendo nada más que tratar. Vamos a suspender el acto. Buenas tardes.